we're here for a turkish bath yes so
that's the luxury angels stacy and i are
marking our final evening before our
surgery tomorrow by getting a turkish
bubble bath
so i feel like it's like a ritual
everybody does to just feel cleansed new
and like re-burst yeah we're ready to
get scrubbed down
[Music]
it's so warm this is the original
marble
this place was built in like the 1500s
in turkish culture it's not only that
you purify your body which purify your
soul which i definitely can use right
now
[Music]
maybe cleopatra
wow
that's a really beautiful
this turkish scrub down it's luxurious
because you have this amazing silky
smooth bubbles that they scrub you down
with
and it's relaxing it's zen i feel like
it's it's a part of our transformation
oh yeah well look goofy
oh
better than georgie that's for sure
yeah
oh my lash oh
well timer say goodbye
everything
from my past has been washed away
scrubbed away
and it can't hurt me anymore
i feel like a new a new darcy
i feel like i've given georgie too much
of myself and i want to get a piece of
me back
yes
i think once i get the surgery even
though i might deal with some physical
pain because of the surgery and stuff
i feel like i'll heal along with that on
the inside too
[Music]